[Music]
and all the reacting news although react
I think they overreacting submitted by
the boy an enraged husband poured
concrete into his wife's car after she
changed her name back to her oh that's
fun haha not the remaining name why to
another man you just leave it no I'm
saying like a same thing
are you still married something smells
good
I don't know the Astra Methodist but I
do know it's you it's my hand lotion
yeah likes no conventional nice
it's Wow Joe I've smelled something
earlier me at me okay
moms did tell Joe he enticed everyone
hmm it smells good so would you guys
like to guess where this takes place
Indiana
India California China Mumbai China's
always man you take California Mexico
New York India earth it's in there yes
mmm
right Berlin New York later on Russia oh
yeah I mean something like this like a
dude pouring concrete and there's pretty
Russians I find out it's not like some
travel do though are Russians just like
like Asian people with white people
outside like Asian people hearts they
are I've ever seen old Russian paintings
yeah it's always like a white guy in
some [ __ ] Mongolian outfit with curly
toe shoes oh yeah yeah I think Russians
are literally like it's that blend of
like Mongolian culture but they're still
white mmm
so what's going on here ah the sixties
in Russia and so a husband found out
that his wife changed her last name
because there was a supermarket
it's called Benny and what that means in
Russian is loyal and so Vinny's the
Supermarket says that they won't be
paying like a little bit less than nine
hundred US dollars per week to anyone
that changes their last name to the name
of the supermarket so that's what his
wife's nine hundred dollars a week no a
little bit less than nine hundred US
dollars and she converted it yeah when I
converted it a week so a week how long I
would do it I want to know that not a
month I don't know for how long
um you know they're saying money like
they're just gonna give you money acting
at no I will be mad cuz I would not be
mad at or any more income to the family
hey here's about four grand a month just
to change your last name and you could
change it back later you know I mean
yeah it he does admit that they were
going through a rough oh my god so she
was down for the team but then he knows
the reason of the name it's not like
some other random name and then he's
like what the [ __ ] you know like are you
cheating on me it's for [ __ ]
groceries yeah yeah yeah I changed my
last name the 99-cent store showed Andy
de anima
if they're going to give me hundred
bucks a week [ __ ] yeah okay so for a
thousand dollars a week for two years
you guys change your name to Joe
I like dick would you do it yeah done
easy right who do I make this check out
ha ha ha
Joe I like dick mr. I know mr. Allah
dick to you they're all separate where
it's gonna be cool because when people
refer to me at the bank excuse me mister
I like dick oh you do excuse me I liked
it yeah some talk on everyone who says
they have to say my name they like dick
here's a video clip of the time oh my
goodness
no I was trying to suction worker no
I'll try to find my details on this and
a lot of different news outlets are
reporting this pretty similarly and
apparently it's like this guy
just went up to some stranger that had
concrete pick on the street like the
concrete truck and here's aku down a
core concrete in this car and I'll pay
you and the person was like sure that's
[ __ ] that's funny how someone be like
okay
no questions asked I being a Russian
culture if you want to like fertilizer
ones down dirt if your culture like
other news a little bit of caviar in
vandalism yeah the Russians are dealt
goes together really well yeah like I
was trying to find like more information
but like other news sources wouldn't
even mention like how he even obtained
the country is done to bashed in this
window sure when I recorded it yeah and
like this person's love it seems like a
woman's recording it yeah so I don't
know here we go
I've been directing yeah pretty much
with you
you see forest right into my wife's car
die bucket oh my god that would you get
lucky the Russian [ __ ] oh my new
chuckling my first siren sound like only
thanks bunny because her car is ten
Utley his car yeah
what is doing what if it dries is that
car like decision now usually there but
there's evidence improve doesn't that no
I don't know how that works in Russia
this does mirror this country really
look like there's a nice to like women
always really it's just like wet mud
yeah just brought home on each other for
people are like Senator ever ever
[ __ ] say hi honey can you believe my
wife changed it a last name to make
$1,000 of the week and I filled it up
Wow that is so sad I'm going to post
this on Instagram the Russian people
must be like Boris potty
for the government
with you cold colorful cement car clean
yeah I guess last names really really
our big deal out there or he's a
manually and don't care the same last
name what's there to be insecure about
you're getting a lot of money a month
and it's for them both isn't it well I
mean what just was saying earlier that
they had some problems right it's like I
wonder what problems they were having no
good she's my [ __ ] not super lucky she
was saying that the husband that she was
not loyal to her husband and so that's
why she's doing this
Oh revenge which is ironic that the name
of the supermarket is maan oil oh she's
a cheater cheater pumpkin eater I give
you his eyes because she changed her
last name that's not being loyal to him
uh but she is that she's bringing
[ __ ] groceries oh great losing her
identity to bring him more money you
know I'd do it for a lifetime supply of
watermelon heartbeat and it's just a
produce in its one fruit for you know
900 bucks a week
a lot of watermelon plus banana plus
Apple plus [ __ ] pumpkin seeds all
kinds of [ __ ] and meats I don't even eat
900 bucks worth of groceries a week I
can't even eat 900 bucks worth of food a
week hmm I can but like that's gonna be
like missions like expensive you could
stun 900 buses cookies maybe but like
that's like expensive Oh it'll be
expensive but like if you did like like
sushi omakase you said not on a bus in a
week it's true
but it's like unrealistic man I can't
even eat that much like not at all the
groceries yeah
$100 with the produce like at the end of
our fries with like 50 bucks a week yeah
yeah I don't buy groceries man yeah we
are [ __ ] up we spend a lot every time
crows research yes because we don't go
on a long time we gotta restock
everything oh yeah yeah there's not a
week if you do the people weekly or even
bi-weekly but it's not it's not that
yeah I'll leave I like a handful of
things you only need to buy a couple of
proteins and some bone also becomes
expensive for people is to kind of make
a new dish every day you got to buy like
50 different kinds of spices and all
kinds of [ __ ] if you have an investment
though for your pantry
yeah but some festive spoils though
unless you're Thomas spices per se but
even a go to you don't want it if I can
use some old ass child yeah okay that's
why I like grocery shopping to people
don't like because you should be going
grocery shopping probably once every
like four days now I could do it now
living in LA you just walk down the
street grab a few items put in a
backpack well I feel like a street rat
like in Agrabah that I could just get
like a half roll in this and a bad and
then I got a dinner I can see love
shopping on groceries I like food at
this thing so just like you handle it
I don't like grocery shoppings either go
upstairs why did um what is required I
know that's the thing a lot of people
are commenting like man I wish I could
see the white space oh I think that's
why I said I don't know the aftermath
Richard no yeah I don't know what
happened after like already phase and
did he get in trouble and then that so
there was comments saying like the
person I had the concrete they can also
be prosecuted just along with the
husband because he helped now that's the
only other thing other than that I got a
guy thinking recording it to like I
don't understand
he didn't care that other people because
it look like another random dude which
is well that's what I'm saying like I
don't understand when people do crimes
how come they want to build a case
against themselves like what what's the
point you know if I don't think it's a
big deal it's like murdering somebody
joke what's the big deal is a Gil
because
like he maybe his name's on the title
and he's like this is my property damage
whatever property I want I owe this [ __ ]
that's wrong maybe has a sacred dream he
always wanted to put some it in a car
and now here's his check
keep feeling what I'm saying by YV the
water and there's a cement look at the
same time as you are because she changed
the last name that's not boy that is my
[ __ ] beacon [ __ ] what's his name huh
go through her name uh nicosia easy one
we should go to Russia restaurant huh I
went to a Russian restaurant Russian
refugees ' I went to a Russian
restaurant
it was pretty good they kind of like
took like classic Russian dishes but
upscale a little bit really like Boris I
mean like potatoes of it's very brined
like fish and [ __ ] like yea orsa the
airport in Moscow and then like we just
had like herring yeah so they'd ever
known for my pickle what but you're not
the airport you know we got Arab
articulate any that I had they've dated
it different it was pretty damnedest it
was like pickled herring in like a warm
potato salad to the pink was the thing
we ate was pink tickle hairy man I
wasn't down we saw the chef's table
where that's all like that's their
staple like after the wars and stuff
like food was just the one that I was
like even difficult hearing in a jar
like our grocery store right now like
the texture is a little bit different
it's kind of good I like you a lot
though borscht like beets
well of course it's the soup rice soup
beeps ooh and then they put like creme
fraiche or sour cream and YUM I like it
it's pretty good yeah I know whatever we
order that day I was like I gotta try
some a lot of these like cold regions
dude it's all like root vegetables
pickled fish you know like dried meat
[ __ ] like it's hard to get nutrients
because it cord yeah no no no man it's
crazy
yeah because they drink old milk you
would think you think Asian people would
be like [ __ ] it 40 feet tall but they
are like in sir
with China northern China there
hellotalk but once again it does hold
and Koreans - these are pure [ __ ] you
eat noodle you know what I am what are
you talking about no but like when we
went to lie for example at Japan
everybody with short ass bug or the
giant in there but they have a lot of
nutritious food do they yeah I don't
know important the protein portions out
there pretty small depending we always
end up you know most about food
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode if you haven't already make sure
to hit that subscribe button because we
upload videos every single day for you
guys now to watch more videos check them
out of here
[Music]